good quote unquote leads
how does that manager define good leads
because here's the thing
if they're defining good leads
by cost
but i don't
i don't define good that way maybe i'm
defining good by amount
i'm just supposed to deliver a lot of
leads
now i'm running a different campaign
than my manager is expecting and any
data i report about the amount of leads
i'm getting
is going to be wrong
because my manager is concerned about
cost and that's the language he is
speaking and i am speaking the language
of amount
so if i don't understand the question to
start with i'm going to report the wrong
data
and i'm not going to answer the question
so first and foremost define the
question what is it that we're trying to
answer what's the problem we're trying
to solve
what am i expected to deliver
define those questions and you'll find
your analytics
then take on a completely different
aspect
because once i know the question
now i can be intentional
in answering the question and this gets
to and i love this hilbern's law of data
intentionality
you see website analytics like google
adobe
all these analytics programs
they track everything
everything that happens on your website
all right and then they put it together
and they report everything they report
all the clicks the actions how people
got there everything they report all
this stuff
the thing is according to this law of
david data intentionality
there is a low intentionality of data
collection meaning
google adobe any analytics program
collects all the data and all the events
that they can
and then you have to decide what's
important
which means
now you're applying a bit of
intentionality
then when it comes to presentation of
the data
google adobe all they do is push out a
bunch of charts and graphs and things
like that and you have to go find what's
important
see there's a low intentionality of data
presentation in analytics
because
all of these programs are meant to fit
any kind of business anywhere around the
world
a coffee shop
you know a small ecommerce site a large
e-commerce site a fortune 500 company
anyone can use google analytics
but are you using it in the right way
for your business
that means you have to be intentional in
how you use it
so
if i have a clear question
i know the question and i need to answer
it that means that i'm going to go about
finding the right data to answer that
question that means i'm going to be
intentional in
finding data using data
then that will help me tell a better
story
then i'll use that data and i will
present it in a way that is focused on
making a presentation
you see what happens is when you just
take charts and graphs and copy it out
of an analytics program and put it into
a presentation
that is a low intention of data
collection and a low intention of data
presentation
no one
will understand that no one will be
persuaded by that
if you want to persuade someone
you cultivate your data
you present it in a way that's easily
understood
and that answers a clear question
that's the key to telling a good story
with data is we when we define the
question we know what data we need so we
have to go find it and then we have to
do something with that data to make it
understood to our audience
this is what i mean google analytics for
example low intentionality we've got a
lot of data here does it answer our
question
we have to go find the data that answers
the question
here's how i know and here's how i
recognize a high intentional data report
number one
it starts with a question
i love this report because it defines
here's the question here's the
opportunity here's what we are analyzing
and it starts with the question
and then everything below
is focused on answering that question
they use data they change the data from
its original source
into a more visually appealing source
and here
they answer the question so we have the
question and the answer right there
that's what makes a good data
presentation in a very small amount of
area
they've defined the question they've
shown the data they answer the question
and it makes it clear for people to
understand what they are communicating
see they're not just
showing a data table that they copy and
pasted
they're re building the data to be more
understandable
here's our goal you see the problem is
when as marketers
we create
all the time
we create persuasive powerful
advertising to persuade people to take
action we do this through creative we do
it through imagery we do it through
headlines and using active words to
persuade people to take action
but yet
when we go to a boardroom or we do a
zoom call and we're supposed to present
data what do we do
we don't use any images we don't use any
active words we don't use any creative
we then default to our left brain and
give a purely logical
data table presentation which doesn't
excite anybody it doesn't engage the
brain
and what we have to realize is as
marketers our job is engaging the brains
of our audience and when we present data
that's another audience it's our
internal audience in just the same way
we know our target audience
we also have a target audience in the
boardroom
and we need to understand who they are
what their needs are what are they
trying to accomplish and the better we
understand our internal audience
the better we can create better messages
better presentations that they will
understand
here's the thing
words and data are processed in the
short term
memory
that's logic
facts
figures
data tables
nobody remembers a data table that they
saw three weeks ago
right
however
we remember
a movie
a television show
a meme
we remember images
we remember video we remember story
why because our brain processes story
our brain processes images in the long
term memory
when we can associate a picture or an
image with a fact it makes it more
memorable and our brain processes this
so much faster than data than tables
than facts and figures
and so if we want to create a persuasive
presentation
we have to
engage the entire brain we have to
become more creative in how we do this
now
kind of the traditional you've got your
you know you've got your right brain
you've got your left brain you know this
is our traditional look at it
neuroscience television tells us you
know a lot more but let's break it down
this way so we know that our right brain
is engaged a little differently
the right brain is the you know hey
left brain is
what are we going to do the right brain
is why
why are we going to do that
what's the what's the story behind this
why are we going to take that action
but you know and so up here is our
conscious
the things we're aware of and the things
that we react to and so in a
presentation most times in data it's
what it's this is the data here's what
it is
whereas our right brain is craving
context
tell me the story what's going on
where'd the data came come from what was
what was the campaign what did the
creative look like so our right brain is
craving images we're craving to see what
that looks like
but yet the left brain
you know and here in our subconscious
these are the things that affect us you
know kind of behind the scenes um
you know and we can look at things this
way
unfortunately the left brain it runs on
facts
figures
you know more logic
things like that but like i said that's
processed in the short term and it's
processed slower
so we need to have a balance here
the the balance is on on the right side
stories
images
uh when you want to know the why
you know anecdotes
anything that adds flavor anything that
adds color
to the information that we're seeing
and here's the point when you engage the
whole brain when you provide some of
that creative along with the logic what
happens is you awaken a part of the
brain
that now is tuned in to your
presentation
they're tuned in to the data and the
story and what happens is it awakens
something called empathy
and when you create empathy
in the brain of your listener
that then creates action
now they're ready to listen to your
recommendation they're ready to hear
what you have to say they're open to now
you know the suggestion of what you want
to present and here's where we're going
to go and here's what we're going to do
and here's why we're gonna do it and
they're with you because you've
presented it in a way that engages the
entire brain and when you produce that
empathy they're more willing to listen
more willing to hear you out
and
hear what you have to say but we have to
engage the full brain now how do we
engage the full brain we're going to
look at a couple of different ways
number one is using a storytelling
structure
now a story
three things that make a good story
number one character who's the character
now i also like to call this this is my
audience okay
and and even i'll i'll even break this
down into my audience a certain segment
all right this is where i build my
context it's this audience it's this
segment all right we're gonna look at
this segment because they're behaving in
a certain way
that either presents a problem or an
opportunity but here's the thing the
problem or opportunity that's conflict
that's why whenever i'm evaluating a
website and i'm evaluating it for
conversion optimization
if i'm evaluating it for user experience
that's friction friction is conflict all
right so anytime i see that there is
friction if there is an obstacle it's
conflict and now i have a story
i just need to know who's my audience
who's my main character and what problem
are they meeting what's what do they
need to overcome and by the way when
they overcome that
well now we get to resolution
how do they overcome this problem now
in business and on our websites our
problems result in low conversion rates
our problems result in
poor user experience
so how do we fix these things
here's the here's the key
we don't just fix them we fix them and
apply a resolution that if we do this
here's the result
and this is where we draw people in and
we give them our recommendation
internally that this is what happens i i
love to say and and even beyond this i
think about this in terms not just of my
business resolution
but my my audience resolution for
example if i'm selling uh you know b2b
software
and
people are having a hard time getting
through my site downloading the app or
doing something like that that's
conflict
and what i'm saying is if they
if we fix this conflict it will allow
people to download this app or allow
them to to buy our software
but see that's my resolution
my resolution is the marketer
the business owners resolution
it allows me to
you know it allows me to save money
and if i save money i take a vacation
or
i hire someone to do something because i
have more money i hire someone to take
some of this pressure off of me
see now
if i'm looking in terms of my audience
and this is the problem we have
internally
we'll focus on our audience
we'll talk about their problem but we
talk about the resolution in terms of
our sales
or our conversion rate
so the problem is we just changed the
story from about our customer to about
us
a clear story is my customer is having a
problem with this and if we solve that
for them this is what it enables them to
do and we have a much clearer resolution
and it's a better story because we
haven't changed the main character
so the story three main elements
character conflict and resolution
here's an example uh working with one uh
company it was b2b software uh it was
lead generation lead management software
and what we found is we had two distinct
audiences two distinct customer groups
that were using this software
we called the first group our
bodybuilders now we call them
bodybuilders because they're all about
performance
performance they use this software to
generate more leads to close more sales
to
it was all about numbers that they
wanted you know goes back to what's a
good lead they wanted a lot of leads and
they wanted a lot of leads fast and they
wanted to close those leads it was all
about performance
we had another customer group who used
the software very differently we called
them our mothers our new mothers
because they were all about relationship
so part of what we do when we're
building a character is we come up with
a clear word and all i have to do is
give a single attribute that describes
them so my bodybuilder was performance
and once internally i said that i said
we've got a bunch of people here and
they act the same way
i said they're all performance oriented
like bodybuilders
all of a sudden internally it's like
this the light went off and they're like
oh yeah
i said but then we've got another group
and they use the software a very
different way they're mothers they are
nurturing
they like relationships
and again the the the stakeholders the
managers are like yes
i see that i understand that see rather
than using data to define the audience
we used picture image to define the
audience
and it helped people identify and view
them
and then internally it got us the
ability to change content change
marketing strategy change all of these
things and it allowed them the sales
people of this software and also our
content to focus on the two groups that
once we realized what kind of customer
this was
we gave them the content we gave them
the information that was focused on
their goal
their goal was nurturing their goal was
performance
and when they saw content that fit that
they were more likely to buy
so developing a clear character that
helps define this
but then also the conflict what prevents
success what obstacles are in front of
them this is where we want to identify
the dragon you know where who is coming
against them what is the problem what's
the friction what's the obstacle define
it clearly because this is what you'll
see in your data many times is
identifying the problem
but then
what's the resolution and this is where
a lot of marketers they're you know
doing analytics or any analysts great at
finding problems well let's figure out
the resolution
what do we do to fix this
this is where you in your presentation
the data makes you look great because
you are presenting the solution
and the solution just happens to make
the business better
so we identify a clear resolution what
do we have to do to make this happen
all right stuart we're in time for our
second poll here now that i've given you
the elements of storytelling have you
ever
been in a presentation where someone
used storytelling
to persuade you to take action have you
ever been exposed to someone who used
this technique in presenting marketing
or marketing data
and we'll give another 15 seconds or so
very curious to see the results of this
one
all right
stewart i can't see the results of that
can you share that with us
oh wow about 50 50.
wow
that's probably one of the closest polls
we've ever seen
that is amazing
amazing
wow
okay
i and then this is part of the thing we
were talking earlier about where to put
this poll because i i was partially
under the impression that you know what
i'm not sure people would know if
storytelling techniques have ever been
used on them in a marketing situation
would you be able to identify it if it
happened and that's why i wanted to put
it after i told you you know here are
the storytelling techniques and if this
has been used maybe some of you it looks
like half of you are saying
yeah
that's why it was so effective and the
other half were saying i wish my
meetings were better
so absolutely absolutely great love to
see that
all right now
that's the presentation side more of my
presentation that if i'm going to walk
people through this if i'm going to
present it in a board room if i'm going
to present it through zoom
the story is the verbal side of my
presentation it's what i'm going to talk
about
now let's talk about slides all right
i've already told you do not copy and
paste data tables nobody wants to see
that now however
here's the the
here's my warning all right not my
warning but here's my the caveat to this
have the data
available
but do
not present it
invariably someone is going to say can i
see the data
at that point i usually like to say
yes you can see it i will send it to you
afterwards
and please let me know your feedback
okay do not sidetrack your presentation
by throwing data tables up on the screen
don't do that
hold it off to the side if someone wants
to see it whether it's you're in the
office or remote
offer to send it afterwards
here's why they'll never open it
they'll never look at it
so that reduces most of it
someone will invariably get the data
look at it but here's the thing you're
going to have a discussion about the
finer points of the data offline
somewhere else not in your meeting
in your meeting you are the star of the
show you are the main character you are
the one who is presenting your findings
don't
let someone sidetrack it by talking
about details
focus your presentation on discovery and
you know and presenting yourself as i
figure this out this is all about you
save the data for later send it
separately
now
which graph enables you to find the
change in attitudes over the past two
years the
fastest which chart enables you to see
this very quickly
i'll give you a few seconds to look at
it
now most of you probably the chart on
the right the spider chart and there's a
reason for this you see on the left is
this typical bar chart and you may say
you know what i'm not going to copy and
paste data tables out of my analytics
program but i'm going to use excel and
i'm going to put the data in excel and
i'm going to let excel create a chart
because it looks better no it doesn't
all right
there are certain charts that work
better to communicate data more
efficiently
and one of the things that i love doing
is when i have the data
to create different charts
create different visualizations so that
i myself can see which one is easier to
understand
but not just that i'm looking at speed
how quickly can i drive attention to the
most important data
my bar chart
does not really effectively show
the change in attitude and the problem
is
so number one i have to read the
question
here is my legend
and then i have five different areas
spread across here so in order to
understand this bar
i have to okay product quality here
what's that that's february 2017 and
then this um okay and and now and i'm
going back and forth to the legend all
right
whereas
in this presentation
very quickly visually i see that these
three areas are the same so i don't have
to look at that these are very different
and they have changed
speed
how quickly can i drive people to the
main point
that's the first
method of evaluating your effectiveness
and communicating data and that's
finding the right chart right graph or
the right visual
that will show the relationships
that will show the change
and that will point people to
the issue
the bar chart is not effective for this
all right
there are certain times where a bar
chart is effective
but only by looking at different
visualizations will you find the one
that enhances the speed of the first
the first data point that's what we're
looking for now there are other ways
that i can enhance this number one is
understanding color and
contrast color and contrast are two of
the most important visual elements in a
presentation
you can see here i love this slide
because of its simplicity
i've got a color wheel i have two words
and it's surrounded by white
it gets your attention
see a lot of times we feel like we have
to load a slide with a lot of
information
when in reality
less
is more
i have only two words in this slide and
i know you've read both words if i have
500 words on a slide i don't know which
words you've read so i want to keep it
very simple and very clear and i can do
that with color and contrast
number one if i go to excel and i put my
data in this is the default data and
this is how it will be shown now the
problem is if i use excel and i just use
the the defaults
i have five different colors repeated
five times which color is the most
important
yeah
we don't know
because
you've got a lot of different colors
what do i want you to look at
see and this is where sometimes i like
the monochromatic approach because if
everything is one color but shaded it
means my boldest
my most contrasting color is the one i
want you to look at
people naturally look at the most
colorful
boldest color most contrasting color
first it's where our eyes naturally go
and so i'm going to change the colors
to
focus on where i want your eyes to go
first and that's the most important data
if you use a lot of color
well the eyes aren't really going to go
anywhere they're going to work around
the page because you're not directing
the eyes
only through color and contrast can you
direct where someone's eyes will go so i
don't use the fault colors in excel
which means i'm going to have to get in
and i'm going to have to kind find a
color scheme
maybe a highlight color that i can use
to direct but then also i may have to
re-order my data
for that type of presentation
here's the key here's what i'm trying to
communicate to you you just can't plug
and play your numbers
you've got to design the slide design
the data and how you want people to look
at it and one of the things i absolutely
love is adobe color wheel all right uh
if i have to present a you know some
data if i had to make a presentation one
thing i can do is i can go put in the
primary colors of my brand uh or of you
know
the brand i'm working with or of my my
presentation style i can put in my my
primary colors and then i can get
different colors
and different ideas so i i love the
monochromatic because it will give me
matching colors that are pleasing to the
eye
i don't have to go in and select it the
adobe color wheel will give me a color
palette that is very very pleasing to
the eye and all i have to do is get the
hex codes
and put that into my presentation and
now i've created a better presentation
that's more visually appealing but also
focuses the eyes on the right
information
here's why
people do not read your slides
they know
people don't read web pages
they just they don't do that we can't
even call uh jacob nielsen is a is a
user experience specialist and he said
that
reading is doesn't even properly
describe what people do online okay let
me i guarantee you nobody has read this
entire sentence
why because it's a bullet point and it
repeats which means it's it it's not
worth my time
i i'm wondering how many of you are like
you know what i didn't read that
sentence it's too long
by the way if you bullet point something
anything in a bullet point should only
have about five to seven words in a
bullet point
beyond five to seven words no one's
going to read it
and so when you do an internal
presentation and you've got bullet
points
keep them down to five to seven words
this sentence nobody's gonna read
because it repeat it returns
by the way if you use a bullet point it
increases readability by twenty percent
if you keep it to five to seven words it
increases readability by about forty
percent
if you bold the first two to three words
it will increase the readability of
those two to three words another forty
percent
everyone read that
maybe you started reading that nobody
read that
eye tracking studies show us people like
short bold words they're easy to scan
because we don't read so when you're
developing your slide be aware of how
you are positioning your text
what is happening now it doesn't mean
that i don't want text on a slide
no we'll talk about that a little bit
later
it means that when i am adding text to a
slide when i'm adding text to data i
need to treat it just like a web page
clear headline
anything that's bold italiced or
underlined people will look at those
words if i use a heavy typeface
you know color size white space
all of these things enhance people's
ability to scan the words
and i can point them to the words i want
them to read by utilizing
this type of markup in my slides or in
my documents or presentations
now
text selection
sans serif
means without the serif is great for
headlines why because it's bold and it's
vertical and it's easy to read as you go
down the page
if you have a paragraph of content
i prefer to use a serif font serif fonts
have been shown to
leave the eyes through longer sentences
by the way online or in a presentation a
paragraph should be no more than two
sentences
no one will read a paragraph of more
than three sentences because
well they won't
that's just our online and and our
behavior we don't like reading
paragraphs so keep your paragraphs short
maybe two sentences at most and maybe
you'll get people to read them
all right now we're getting to putting
together our presentation
got to evaluate yourself
number one ask yourself am i answering
the question we're going all the way
back to the beginning what was the
defined question does your data and does
your story answer the question
now
does the overall data that you have do
you have extraneous data do you need to
strip some things away what is not
relevant to the question
a lot of times i love to get rid of you
know
get rid of the axis
get rid of the lines
get rid of the a lot of times i like to
get rid of the legend and integrate it
can i integrate the legend into the data
itself to make it easier to read and
associate the data with the you know
with the the visual
this is where it takes a heavy
evaluation to eliminate things that are
not necessary to the message
we focus on adding data and you know
putting a data chart in there but what's
really necessary
do we need these lines do we need all
that no we don't
we're just trying to get the
the relevant information across and
eliminate what's unnecessary
so here's my seven c's here's the
checklist i you know i'll tell you uh
you know download this write this down
here is my seven point checklist for a
data presentation
number one is clarity how quickly can
people reach
the primary message or the primary data
point visually how quickly can they
reach that insight
the content how easy can they grasp the
entire presentation the entire slide
maybe you've got some additional nuance
beside the primary point
credibility
trust symbols citations references
you know additional data that you'll
send later or things on the slide but
let people know this is where i found
the data this is where it comes from
then visually you'll notice the first
three are all about
the information itself
the last are all about how am i
presenting it visually
is my most important information
the easiest to see
it's usually contrast and color
also i want to look at my color and see
is the color enhancing my presentation
or am i using too much color
and it could be taking away
from
guiding people to the important
information
context
overall
am i answering the question and does
everything i have on this slide answer
that question
and then am i showing a comparison
am i making a comparison saying that
this is good and here's why it's good
because of this data
what comparative data am i bringing
now here's the model to present data
insight action and impact
what do i mean by that
let me tell you this ninety percent of
ninety percent of marketers do this
fairly well
and that is report what they see
we got this many visitors to the site
okay that's a good observation what is
it what'd you learn okay about 90 of
marketers report
insight okay here's what i saw here's
what i learned and that makes the report
about
nine percent of marketers
report action
that based on my insight here's the
recommended action only about nine
percent of marketers do that
then there's the one percenters these
are the top marketers these are the ones
that distinguish themselves and these
are the ones that get attention
why because they not only report the
insight they not only recommend action
but they give a financial impact
statement
of if we do this
this is how it will impact our revenue
this is how it will save us money
you see you want to get a stakeholder's
attention you want to get a manager's
attention
you frame your presentation with an
economic impact to your recommendation
and you're in the one percent
that's what gets people's attention
now you can only do this when you know
who your audience is and you know what's
important to them
just like
our target audience in marketing our
internal management our internal
stakeholders
we've got to know that audience what
drives them what motivates them what's
going to excite them the better we know
that the better decision we're going to
make
and so and and if you know avinash
kaushik i kind of took this from him but
i built on it
built on it because basically i'm going
to change my report i'm going to change
my reporting based on who i am giving
the report to
you see if i'm going to give data to a
campaign owner or director
i'm going to curate a little bit of the
data but i don't need to add explanation
because they know what to do
if i'm going to go to maybe a vp level
or marketing director or someone like
that
i'm going to have less data
but i'm also going to add my insight
action and impact but i might not need
to add as much and they might want to
see a little more data as i go further
up to stakeholders to cmos
i'm going to display
less data
and more
here's what to do
here's why i'm going to give a detailed
explanation i'm not going to use any
acronyms
in my reporting and i'm going to focus
on insight action and impact and that
always has a dollar sign attached to it
what does that look like
it looks like this
like i said marketers are really good
insight
insight hey here's a here's a campaign
uh that is driving a lot of mobile users
here we are we're getting about 60 of
our visits from mobile however
two percent of our conversions
we're losing people
and what this shows is that this site is
driving a lot of people from mobile but
it does not have a mobile optimized
landing page and so the conversion rate
for a mobile user is point zero one
percent oh that's terrible
that's our insight this is bad
mobile's our number one source of
visitors but delivers the lowest amount
of leads well what do we do that's
action here's our here's our ten percent
of marketers well we redesign
okay we redesign for mobile we
redesigned the entire site what should
we do
uh and you know we explain a high bounce
rate this means if you gave a party and
you invited 100 people
and 100 people showed up but 87 left
before they got to the front door that's
bad
and that we have to explain it in a way
that's visual for people to understand
that
and also we've got a terrible conversion
rate because the industry average
conversion rate and this leads us to
impact
now
the impact is and by the way this is not
how this was presented to
stakeholders this is more presented to
directors managers that this is a
problem
and then it was elevated but here's what
they do if we have an average value of a
lead at 75 dollars
and we improve our conversion rate from
0.07 to 0.1 well that's an increase of
70 leads
incremental value of those 70 leads is
21 000 a month if we make that change
but here's where you make the difference
if we don't do
anything
for three months
we lose sixty three thousand dollars
now that
see
fear of missing out loss that motivates
people that's a neurological fact we
don't like losing things but here's
where here's where they took it to the
next level
the industry average is .75 conversion
rate
if we redesign our website and we get an
industry average conversion rate
that is an additional
625 000 per month in revenue
but if we don't do anything
we lose 1.8 million dollars every three
months that we don't take action
that's powerful
that's what drives action that's what
gets you into that one percent that says
here's the economic impact of doing this
or doing nothing
now how did that get communicated
very quickly
they
you do it just like you do on social
media
a picture a headline and a description
we call this the phd okay the phd what's
your image what's your metaphor who's
your character that's your image your
statement your headline that's your your
statement that's your obstacle and how
did we overcome this obstacle or what's
the problem with the obstacle and then
the description the description is where
i put my call to action here's what
we're going to do to move from conflict
to resolution and here's the slide that
was shown to the vp the the cmo here's
why we need to redesign the site because
a bad experience on mobile creates a
loss of 1.8 million dollars every three
months
and then here was the description here's
what we need to fix
simple clear
this is data presentation but it
presents it in a way that they can reach
the conclusion within seconds
and then
we
we the data analysts we the marketer we
explain why we explain our research and
everything that goes on behind it and we
tell the data story and that's what
makes a powerful presentation
all right stuart i'm opening this up for
poll number three and then we'll take
questions
and on this poll i think you can mark as
many of the skills as you like
and just about 10 seconds left
uh very good
somebody asked what's pay-per-click pvc
that's interesting because bar graph is
well okay yeah okay i'm looking at the
bar graph trying to figure out how that
lines up but yeah all right it doesn't
total to a hundred percent
oh that's right
multiple yeah multiple selections that's
right that's right
oh yeah okay
great
all right hey this is what makes the
presentation great is questions
uh your questions are what makes this
presentation work because now you could
take everything i said
uh but i want you to apply it so what
are some of the questions you have about
presenting data
so we have a few um that are
have come in from the audience
and um
so alexandra asks a basic question which
is
how when to use bar charts when to use
pie charts
and i think to generalize that would be
um what what's the best way to learn the
different choices
for data presentation for charts and
when to use which ones
great great question
um i don't like pie charts unless they
are very obvious
all right and if you're familiar that's
that's what i call
the obvious
pie chart looks like pac-man all right
that's it that is an obvious pie chart
because if you use a pie chart with too
many selections or too many options
i don't know what's important i don't
know where you're focusing my attention
and a lot of times a pie chart just has
random colors
so i don't know what's important or even
if i've got 20 responses in a pie chart
and it's all monochromatic i still don't
know what's important because now i have
to look at a legend
so a pie chart
unless there is a big obvious
difference in the data you're presenting
is not usually a good option
the bar chart again
is it clear what we're presenting bar
charts are good for comparison
but many times sometimes we've got to
stack it
uh
in some sort of order to make it easy to
see
so really it's just a matter of play
around with it um don't just get the
default
but maybe stack it in a way that makes
sense maybe put the highest to lowest um
try different things
that will help you see the data quickly
uh i i just found the more
more visual methods i try
i learn something as i'm putting the
data together so don't be afraid to try
different methods
yeah i like the point that you made when
you talked about the spider chart was
that
you tried
different chart types until you see one
that
um
makes the differences or the important
insight
more obvious than others yep so that's
that's great we have a couple of
interesting questions one from mark
do you have some ideas or insight into
managing a meeting
where one of the stakeholders is very
keen about getting into nitty-gritty
details
and
derailing the presentation
yep well and that is i typically see
that when you're putting charts and
graphs on the screen
the more data you feed someone like that
the more they're going to challenge the
data
you see that's why when i stop putting
charts and graphs and i start putting
more visual
uh you know like that spider chart
there's not a lot to argue with right
there
um and now
i'm in control of the narrative i'm in
control of the story i'm telling the
story
and yeah they'll interrupt it and go
ahead ask for the data i'll send it to
you afterwards
just eliminate
eliminate that don't don't even allow
that um now if they've got a problem
with that deal with that offline but the
meeting is yours the meeting is for you
to present what you learned we're not
here to argue data
uh and so go into the go into the
meeting with that mentality that hey
fine let's talk about the data in the
nitty gritty offline
out of the meeting somewhere else not
here
uh
rojita asks what what if a chart is
easier for me but it's not easier for my
audience
good good that's where i like to get
feedback of other peers that i'm working
with
uh
you know just like anything else
sometimes practice helps us become
better
it's the same thing with presenting data
ask someone else to look at it and see
if it makes sense to them and they may
offer some helpful pointers or
feedback that will enable you to make
some uh changes or improvements to it so
always ask those around you to see if
you can get some feedback on that
we're getting a burst of questions
coming in and i'm gonna put all of this
in advance because we won't be able to
handle many more of them but um
i do have um
one
question from akita who asks uh even
though she shows a data student data
studio detailed report
her manager always asks
to add insights and she's not quite sure
what's missing
um
and
the criticism that comes from the
manager you're not showing your
expertise
yeah so
um
what points out of your presentation
today should she focus on
to help solve that problem
insight
action
impact
what did you see what did you learn
what do you recommend
and what's the
economic or the value impact of taking
the action that you're recommending you
start doing those three things in your
presentations and it will show your
expertise
okay
um
one
question from bob lee is uh if you're
giving a presentation
that's going to take an hour or two
hours
is it better to do it in one straight
shot or should it be
broken up into pieces
you and i are talking about like that
yeah we were talking about this earlier
uh i have a hard time sitting on the
couch watching tv for an hour uh so i
can't imagine sitting through a data
presentation and i do it all the time
okay um it's it's knowing your audience
uh what do you what is your audience
prepared for
um i'll tell you right now on zoom if
you're presenting through zoom
it's not the same as being face to face
you don't have the time uh you don't
have the patience uh
we can endure longer periods face to
face
uh a lot of that is the sound quality
it's it's the visual we're not around
people so people have less patience uh
and and
you know something that's 30 minutes in
person
uh in zoom it feels like an hour so
know your audience know what know what
they are think about what can be done uh
maybe on a document and
what can help assist that uh but i would
look at how can i make this shorter more
pleasing because one thing i learned is
everyone likes to be let out of a
meeting early
there you go
um
elizabeth asks how do you introduce
storytelling and finance where it's all
about numbers and finance
and
it's related to other questions um one
of them from saeed that asks about how
to
interpret all the kpis and understand
the impact and present those
um
quickly and efficiently
how do you translate highly technical um
or statistical data into these types
of clear stories
wow good question um even in finance
part of it is you've got to go find the
story and i usually find the story is
you know who's our audience who are we
working with
and this gets to
finding some of your internal data does
your company have data about the people
you're working with the audiences what
are their motivations you know do you
have a persona developed in-house
because that can help you find the
audience and and start that story
um
you know a lot of times it's just
you know thinking considering
uh researching see what data you have
internally that can help you help guide
you with that uh but again just take
that simple thing who's the character
what's their obstacle and what's
resolution
take that framework and and look for
ways to apply that with audiences with
people with segments
think about how that applies
um the other question was uh talking
about kpis and maybe stuart we do that
for our next webinar uh it's how to how
to measure and apply kpis but also tell
the story about what's happening so
because that's a that's a question for a
whole another hour
super uh we have time for i think the
last couple of questions here which um
one of them is from simone who
says she's new to digital marketing and
finds google analytics
difficult to understand
without a lot of practice so
how does one gain practice with that and
does any digital marketing role
have to work with analytic systems
which i think i know the answer to that
but i'll let you in
you know there's no formal training for
marketers who need to do analytics uh
you're not going to find it at many if
any universities uh if you're in a
marketing program
very few universities offer digital
analytics as as a course much less uh
even mentioning uh because you're gonna
get a traditional marketing education
and then maybe they'll add some digital
on top of it but very rarely in
marketing i find people have any
education in analytics so everything you
find analytics wise it's going to be
through a third party provider it's
going to be online it's going to be
certificate programs that's where you're
going to get the education about
analytics uh unless you you know teach
yourself which you know there's a lot of
information out there and there's a lot
that you got to sift through to get
there and there are some good analytics
courses and tools
that you can get through simply learn
some of them in our marketing programs
but also in our
analytics or our business uh
intelligence programs um
and i think the last question i had
was from our youtube audience muhammad
asks
when is it best to use descriptive
statistics and when to use inferential
statistics when you're doing
presenting data or analyzing your your
results
yeah whatever helps me tell the story
more effectively
um
i the the biggest problem
that i find with people who who feel
they're pretty adept at this is too much
data
um
knowing where to scale back and knowing
what data
moves my story along
and which data slows my story down
uh and that's reading your audience
and so i i don't look at you know when
to use what type of data i'm looking at
my data is how quickly does it help me
tell the story
does it and then if there are questions
about a particular part
then i can go back and explore that more
in depth but my initial presentation is
going to be very clear and concise
focusing on the problem and solution at
hand
then
if we need to do a character study if we
need to look more at that conflict i
have the data available and we'll talk
about it there but my main point is to
quickly
get to the point
then if we need to discuss data then
i'll bring up when i need to
but i don't want to distract from the
primary purpose
um we're a bit over time so
unfortunately i have to cut off the
questions and answers here
um
but
i apologize to
all the uh audience members who asked
the questions didn't get a chance to
have them answered
and
please come back to us for future
webinars for more chances to do that i
wanted to say thank you to matt
uh for being here today i forgot to put
your linkedin information you know
uh uh can
people connect with you on linkedin
through just uh searching your name
yeah uh matt bailey site logic uh matt
bailey's site logic is how you can find
me on linkedin or just plain sight logic
s-i-t-e
like in website
sitelogic.com
uh you'll find my website i've got a
regular podcast where i talk about
marketing and cultural issues and uh you
know we just had one on paid search and
how frustrating the new smart campaigns
are uh so that's the latest podcast uh
but yeah connect with me on linkedin i'd
love to know that you attended today and
any questions you have there go ahead
and ask them on linkedin and i should
have some time later today to answer
those but that's matt bailey's site
logic on linkedin or sitelogic.com
okay great
uh you can also connect to um
simplylearn through our
social media channels
at facebook twitter linkedin
we will be sending a follow-up email for
the webinar so that you will receive a
link to today's recording
um so you can go back and take a look at
the advice that matt's given
and we'd like you to keep an eye out for
invitations to future simply learn
webinars
we'd love to see you then and
thanks all for being here
that's the end of our webinar today
take care
thank you everyone
you